i don't know about you guys but i still
can't stop playing elden ring to try and
uncover every secret this game has to
offer i was getting a little demoralized
with the lore and the game in general
for a while but once i started thinking
outside the box it really revitalized my
love for the game as i definitely now
believe that the game was intentionally
designed to be viewed from all kinds of
different perspectives and
interpretations especially since i
started using this freecam mod not only
to record more cinematic shots for fully
produced videos like you're seeing right
now but also just to look more closely
at honestly everything in this game
today we're gonna look at some more
weird but interesting things that my
community and i have found recently we
are really quickly coming up on 100 000
subscribers so make sure to do all the
nice youtube things to help out the
channel if you really want to before we
continue i'd like to talk about our
sponsor for today's video naraka
bladepoint that's coming out with a
brand new map called holoroth to
celebrate its one year anniversary
august 18th through the 22nd the game
will be free to play on steam and epic
games it'll also be 50 off through
august 29th on steam epic games and xbox
plus the game is free if you already
have the xbox game pass you can have a
chance to win a 50 amazon gift card if
you reply to the pinned comment below
saying happy birthday in araka followed
by something you really enjoy about the
game the person with the most likes to
their comment will win and i'll send you
a message in the next few days if you do
if you didn't already know naraka
bladepoint is a battle royale game that
features fast paced melee combat insane
mobility options and a vast arsenal of
weapons to choose from they even have a
new pve game mode called showdown that
has its own unique characters and combat
system compared to the pvp it even has
its own specific challenge stages based
on the hero that you pick with each hero
having its own corresponding storyline
make sure to go check it out today and
thank you naraka bladepoint for
sponsoring this video
so our first group of interesting
discoveries has to do with the merchants
that are randomly spread throughout the
game some musicians in my most recent
stream pointed out that the merchants
who have this violin-like instrument are
apparently accurately playing the
instrument meaning that the hand
movements motions and animations are
almost exactly how you would accurately
play this style of instrument in real
life each change in the tone of the
music being played is followed with an
accurate change in hand position take a
look
[Music]
also the music here is apparently
playing tribute to german's boss theme
from bloodborne it's not exactly the
same but definitely sounds similar
enough to take notice of i'll show you a
comparison now
[Music]
the corrupted merchant in the cathedral
of the forsaken is also playing music
but i haven't been able to figure out if
this song is playing tribute to anything
in my opinion it's likely just sad music
that the developers put here as a joke
because they knew that they designed the
most difficult platforming section in
the game in this location so at least
we're being soothed with relaxing music
while we follow our deaths over and over
again final weird thing about the
merchants but a couple of them have very
suspect and funny sounding laughs after
being killed
oh
could you
what have i ever done
speaking of death sounds and dialogue
and i am so so sorry to everyone out
there for doing this but muriel's
dialogue after being attacked is
actually quite interesting in addition
muriel has a massive health bar for
being a non-boss which makes sense when
he tells us that he can't be wounded or
die stop it please
my flesh is akin to stone i cannot be
wounded
i cannot die
but nor will i cause any harm unto you
cease your futile efforts
if you talk to him after attacking him
he will make you feel so bad about
yourself it reminds me of a disappointed
dad with some very wise words
are you quite finished take this
opportunity to learn to master your
emotions
worry not i take no offense
but others are not always so forgiving
some take to anger
others sorrow
bonds are fragile things
won't to break under strain
and once they're broken
everything is lost
with not to gain and if you're still
curious yes muriel can die it is
absolutely horrible and i feel awful
about myself for even getting a clip of
this i did it so you don't have to
regarding more on this area is the
church of vows where we just murdered
muriel is this statue where you can
offer celestial due to atone for your
sins most players already know this but
if you didn't you can use this just in
case you've antagonized an npc and can't
continue their quest line you can atone
for your sins here the npc will forgive
you and you can then resume that quest
line just know it doesn't fully work if
you fully kill an npc they are gone
forever if you do that
however i found this exact same statue
in noxtella which is conveniently
located directly below the church of
vows this statue is clearly representing
the nox which their armor set reads that
they had been banished by the greater
will to the deep underground where they
now live under a false night sky and
await a new age of the coming stars and
their lord of night if we read about the
celestial dew that we can offer this
knox statue it tells us that once upon a
time the stars of the night sky guided
fate and this is a recollection of those
times this reminds me of ronnie's
questline which actively tells us that
her fate is guided by the stars stay
tuned for a potential lore video on this
subject and let me know what you think
as well next up is this sound effect
from the flame of frenzy outside the
frenzied flame village there's a very
unique sound here that i can't quite put
my finger on sometimes when i listen
very closely it's almost like there's a
woman singing or humming very quietly in
the background of this normally very
chaotic in-game moment maybe i'm just
hearing things and it's intentionally
designed to make a chaotic sound which
would fit the theme very well but take a
listen
last thing we're going to talk about
today has to do with the world map if
you haven't noticed this before there
are several locations on the map where
rune etchings are drawn onto the map
some of these are written over what
looks like labeled banners already drawn
onto the map but other rune drawings can
be seen in random locations as well
there's a possibility that there's a
hidden language within the game my
stream and i even tried to decipher
these rune letters but obviously failed
miserably in doing so runes like this
can be seen in many different ways
throughout the game so hopefully someone
smarter than myself could potentially
determine if this really is a language
that can be translated somehow that
could really help in a lot of avenues of
discovery throughout the game if that's
possible but i really doubt it also in
regards to the map if you're like me
you've been very curious about this
middle section of the map that has this
ominous cloud drawn in here i originally
thought this was just to fill space for
an otherwise empty part of the map
that's just the ocean but when i zoomed
in closer i found it very interesting
that they just left a giant unfilled
texture block in this location obviously
without the use of this camera tool the
player would never be able to notice
this so it could just be an oversight i
still find it very odd and it makes me
think that something may have been here
at some point in development but was
otherwise just cut out another
interesting area on this map is up to
the north where we can see this meteor
drawn onto the map that is seemingly
crash-landed into the ocean here however
when we try to take a closer look at
this location there is no meteor to be
found there are these weird triangular
textures that are seemingly just left
here it really just makes me think that
there was originally something here and
was just cut out of the game later in
production but also could just be an
oversight in an area that will never be
naturally seen by the player again let
me know what you guys think about all of
this stuff and that's all i've got for
you today thank you for watching the
video huge shout out again to naraka
bladepoint for sponsoring the video it
helps the channel out a ton make sure to
check the pin comment below to
potentially win a 50 amazon gift card if
you do want it other than that i will
see you all in the next video take care